et tout de suite c'est vu dans aussi
bienvenue dans vue de Russie la
chronique hebdomadaire qui analyse la
propagande de Vladimir Poutine sur fond
de guerre en Ukraine avec Elena
Volochine comme chaque semaine bonjour
Elena bonjour Stéphanie il y a le
frontière on l'a vu un frontière
physique en Ukraine et on a beaucoup
parlé de la mobilisation lancé par
Vladimir Poutine pour envoyer combattre
les Russes un autre front et moins
visible celui-ci c'est le front
idéologique en Russie immobilise
notamment les écoliers les enseignants
pour soutenir l'opération spéciale comme
l'appelle la lumière Poutine oui c'est
un front qui s'est rappelé cette semaine
au Conseil des ministres que tient
traditionnellement Vladimir Poutine en
visio 2023 a été déclaré en Russie
l'année de l'enseignant et du précepteur
le ministre de l'Éducation a servi kraft
sof a été invité à cette occasion à
présenter les événements prévus dans le
cadre de cette année à travers le pays
et son intervention elle est comme
toujours retransmise en direct par
toutes les chaînes de télévision russe
et le ton de cette information est comme
toujours dogmatique écoutez
un enseignant avec un grand E devient
aujourd'hui un guide vers le monde des
connaissances et de la vérité la vérité
sur notre grand pays on peut dire que
nos écoles nos collèges et nos
universités sont aujourd'hui sur la
ligne de front les pédagogues doivent
lutter contre les faits et les intox
provocants lutter contre l'agression et
biologique contre notre pays et nos
enfants
voilà donc les éléments du mythe qui
sont ressassés comme toujours dans cette
intervention les enseignants ils
seraient là pour transmettre la vérité
aux enfants quelle vérité celle de
Vladimir Poutine car tout autre vérité
la vérité elle-même d'ailleurs est
interdite en Russie cette vérité qui
peint le bon rôle de la Russie au
détriment de celle de l'agression russe
contre l'Ukraine cette dernière elle est
qualifiée comme l'a exprimée ce ministre
d'agression idéologique contre la Russie
pour peu qu'elle serait dite par
quelqu'un il s'agirait donc d'en
prémunir les enfants cette aliénation de
ses enfants à cette réalité parallèle en
Russie elle se traduit depuis des années
par une multitude de programmes
d'éducation dite patriotique la zone de
cette grande guerre en Ukraine et bien
c'est cette éducation a pris encore plus
d'ampleur vous voyez ce qui se passe par
exemple dans les écoles russes depuis la
rentrée dernière celle de septembre
dernier dans ce reportage de la
télévision russe nous sommes le 5
septembre 2022
l'une des innovations de cette rentrée
scolaire chaque semaine dans les écoles
de Russie débutera désormais par la
levée du drapeau et le chant de l'hymne
du pays
[Musique]
une nouvelle matière deviendra aussi la
tradition chaque lundi il y aura une
leçon intitulée discussion sur ce qui
importe la première leçon de ce genre a
été animée par Vladimir Poutine Academy
grade aujourd'hui dans toutes les écoles
du pays les écoliers ont discuté avec
leurs enseignants de ce qui les
préoccupe le plus et ils ont été
informés sur les traditions l'histoire
la culture la science moderne la nature
et la littérature de leur pays
alors en quoi consiste cette nouvelle
matière intitulée discussion sur ce qui
importe alors ce sont des leçons d'une
demi-heure tous les lundis elles sont
obligatoires pour tous les enseignants
et les élèves de 6 à 18 ans soit de la
primaire au lycée tous les supports
pédagogiques ils sont en ligne ils sont
en libre accès donc regardez à les
thématiques elles sont diverses ça va
des fêtes nationales au potentiel
nucléaires de la Russie en passant par
les symboles la Constitution qui ont le
rappel a été réécrite par Vladimir
Poutine ou encore les valeurs familiales
et intergénérationnelles l'une de ces
leçons est consacrée au héros de la
patrie c'est un thème récurrent dans la
propagande de Vladimir Poutine les
objectifs de cette leçon tel qu'ils ont
été définis par le ministère russe de
l'éducation pour les enfants LCP dès le
CP donc les voici il s'agit d'inculquer
aux élèves je cite une opinion positive
envers les valeurs du devoir du service
à la patrie en clair dès l'âge de 6 ans
et bien les enfants ils sont éduqués
dans l'idée qu'ils doivent mourir qu'il
que c'est noble de mourir pour défendre
sa patrie et regarder dans les rangs de
je rappelle cette organisation créée en
2016 par le ministère russe de la
Défense elle compte aujourd'hui
officiellement un million 240 000 jeunes
Russes abreuvés à l'éducation militaire
et patriotique dans les rangs de cette
organisation et bien officiellement sur
leur site que vous voyez en ce moment à
l'écran et bien déjà 9 élèves ou anciens
élèves sont morts sur le front de
l'opération spéciale en Ukraine le plus
jeune avait 20 ans et dans l'esprit de
ses enfants et de ses jeunes il s'agit
bien de défendre son pays et non
d'agresser le pays voisin oui vous allez
l'entendre dans ce poème destiné au
combattant russe en Ukraine il a été
enregistré mise en ligne par des élèves
de l'équivalent d'une classe de première
d'un lycée de Moscou écoutez
[Musique]
de la guerre heureuse ces écoliers ils
croient ça rappelle vraiment la
propagande soviétique pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale oui par le lien
générationnel la propagande de Vladimir
Poutine elle entend ce lien direct entre
ce qui est réapproprié par cette
propagande comme la grande victoire du
peuple soviétique contre les nazis et la
dénazification que prenons que prétend
aujourd'hui mener Vladimir Poutine à
travers son agression de l'Ukraine dans
le cadre de cette éducation patriotiques
les tarus il a aussi lancé une vaste
opération consistant en ce que les
écoliers écrivent des lettres au front
au combattants russe regardez ce clip et
il est réalisé par le ministère russe de
la Défense pour promouvoir cette action
[Musique]
les lettres qu'on nous écrit à l'arrière
garde sont très importantes
[Musique]
on sera de retour avec cette victoire
c'est ma
gratitude
libérez le monde du nazisme c'est
l'histoire moderne telle que les
écoliers russes la prennent dans la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine oui
l'histoire passée est présente telle
qu'elle est enseignée dans les écoles
russes telles que les réécrites la
géographie aussi regardez cette carte
elle est extraite dans des supports
vidéos de ces fameux cours du lundi
c'est nouveau cours patriotiques cette
carte de la Russie est engloutie non
seulement les territoires de l'Ukraine
effectivement un excès par la Russie
mais aussi l'eau c'était du Sud
géorgienne les îles Kouriles disputaient
avec le Japon ou encore la Biélorussie
qui est un état tout simplement à part
cette carte ce n'est autre qu'une
projection du rêve impérialiste de
Poutine mais elle est présentée aux
écoliers russes comme étant celle de la
Russie d'aujourd'hui la réalité de la
Russie d'aujourd'hui une réalité
parallèle donc et un endoctrinement à
l'échelle de ce pays qui est déjà grand
et les formes de ce soutien sont
multiples oui regardez ça va des
écoliers qui fabriquent des bougies pour
les soldats qui sont dans les tranchées
aux étudiants qui leur cousent des
uniformes le rutube l'équivalent russe
de YouTube puisque YouTube est interdit
a été interdit en Russie il regorge de
ses clips montrant ses actions regardé
par exemple cette extrait de concert ça
se passe dans une petite ville de
l'Extrême-Orient russe voyez les paroles
de ce poème tel qu'il a été récité
durant ce concert
o gâteau
si vous n'y
[Musique]
voilà des Russes 5 heures soutenant la
guerre en Ukraine serait pour la paix et
la vérité une race slave supérieure et
les nains on est dans un réappropriation
du discours devenu totalitaire on peut
le dire de Vladimir Poutine oui et mais
parfois dans cette société assez petits
qui doit paraître pourtant unis autour
du projet du président ça dérape un
petit peu ce lundi une réunion en
présentiel et sur zoom à filtrer sur les
réseaux sociaux vous allez le voir il
s'agit d'une réunion de fonctionnaires
de l'État russe chargé justement
d'élaborer ces programmes d'éducation
patriotique et ces fameux cours du lundi
il se dispute sur le fait d'inclure ou
non comme thématique dans ses cours du
lundi l'éducation on meurt et
l'éducation sexuelle écoutez
je suis contre le fait d'interdire
l'éducation sexuelle les adolescents ont
des rapports sexuels des filles tombent
enceintes à 14 ans
qu'il y a des viols dans les écoles ça
ne les intéresse pas mais après en avoir
entendu parler ils commettent des viols
dans les toilettes vous n'en avez pas
entendu parler nous aussi tout ça la
propagande occidentale destinée à
dépeupler la Russie
comment proposez-vous d'inculquer aux
enfants les rapports sexuels
traditionnels
c'est pour cela qu'il doit y avoir des
cours d'éducation sexuelle alors je
résume selon la première responsable il
faudrait éduquer les enfants en fait que
les rapports sexuels doivent se faire
entre un homme et une femme la deuxième
responsable lui dit non il ne faut pas
du tout éduquer les enfants au rapport
sexuel parce que sinon il deviendront
des violeurs et les cours d'éducation
sexuelle c'est un projet occidental
destiné à des peupler la Russie donc
dans cette réalité parallèle russe et
bien certains rétrograde peuvent encore
apparaître comme des progressistes pour
peu qu'il se dispute avec plus rétrograd
plus rétrograde que parce que tout est
relatif comme disait l'autre merci
beaucoup el